asp.net core from microsoft is one of
the most popular web frameworks
experience developer brugin patel will
teach you how to use dotnet 6 which is
the latest version hi guys and welcome
to dot net mastery my name is broken and
in this course we will walk through the
basic foundations of dot net core
application
we will be using dot net 6 in this
course along with visual studio 2022
dot net core has been a buzzword in the
industry for a while
and recently it has been gaining more
and more attention because of the
efficiency and the advantages that it
brings
so first let's take a look at what are
all the exciting topics that we will
cover in this course
foundation is a basic element of any
building and that will be the first
thing that we will learn as we explore
the fundamentals of net core and its
evolution
then it's critical to understand what is
new in darknet 6 when it comes to an mvc
application
so i will highlight the new features in
darknet 6 with respect to the mvc
application
we will be using entity framework core
to set up database connection string and
perform all the database related
operation
once we have entity framework code
configured we will be performing grunt
operations on any model
crud stands for create read update and
delete
so while we perform the grud operations
we will also understand how client-side
and server-side validations work with
net core
we will display nice alerts using temp
data and toaster.js
now while we learn all of this one
critical piece is error solving when it
comes to any programming i will display
you some of the common errors and how
will you approach those errors and
resolve them
lastly we will deploy our application to
azure and we will see everything live
including sql server
which will be hosted on azure as well
so you can see there is quite a few
things that we will be learning in this
course
let's get started with all of that from
the next video
in this video let me show you the demo
application that we will be building
we will start with an empty project and
then we will use boots watch theme to
add a nice styling
next we will be building a category grud
project
so when you click on category in the
navigation bar it will open up the page
and it will display all the categories
first thing that you notice here is we
have a create category button when we
click there it takes us to category
create and here without populating
anything if you press the create button
we have default client-side validation
not just that we also have some server
side validation
like if we enter both name and display
order to be same and hit the create
button we have a server side validation
that display order cannot exactly match
the name
then we have a back to list button here
to go back to our index page with the
category list
we can edit any of the existing category
and as soon as you edit or create
something we have nice toaster alerts
that you can see
lastly we will implement the delete
functionality and on that also we will
have our alerts
so we will see server side client-side
validation we will implement toaster
alerts and take a look at temp data
not only that once we complete the
application we will be deploying that to
azure
so that will give you a complete flow of
the application
as we deploy things to azure along with
our database
so with that let's start on this from
the next video
let's take a look at all the tools that
we will use in this course
we will be using dot net 6 for our
application
so make sure to install the latest
version of darknet 6.
for the ide we will be using visual
studio
the version that i will be using is
visual studio 2022
there are lots of advanced features in
2022 as compared to 2019
so you can always install the free
version of visual studio 2022
for our database we will be using sql
server
so first you will have to install sql
server and then you should install ssms
which is sql server management studio if
you have older version of ssms that's
completely okay
as long as you're able to connect to sql
server on your local machine we will be
using that connection string and
everything will work
so once you install all three of these
softwares let's continue from the next
video
in this video i want to walk you through
the journey of dot-net core
net core is probably the biggest change
that the dot net language has
encountered
in 2002 microsoft introduced web forms
which was a revolution at that time
webforms has its drawbacks and there was
a need to overcome all of them
because of that the dotnet team came up
with a new architecture which was dotnet
mvc
now even though i love mvc and i have
built many applications in mvc it had
its flaws
like it was created on top of the
components for web forms
because of that it was tied to iis and
ultimately windows operating system
but with the evolution of web
development microsoft had to keep up
with the changing technology
finally in june of 2016 microsoft
released asp.net core and it was the
first version
now.net core is built on top of the
new.net core framework it is completely
rewritten and it is a cross-platform
version hence it is not tied with
windows
also.net core was built with cloud in
mind
so it is extremely robust with that
then in august of 2018 microsoft
released.net core 2 and the team has
been active with releasing new versions
there was a big change from dotnet 2.1
to 2.2 because we had to update quite a
few class libraries and there were few
challenges
but since then dot net core team has
been releasing new versions with 3 3.1
and net 5 which was released in november
of 2020
after that there is dotnet 6 which will
be released in november of 2021
we will be using the preview version but
whatever we learn will be the same once
dotnet 6 is released
so this is a small overview of all
the.net frameworks and their evolution
that being said why should one use
dotnet core as compared to the
classic.net
dot net core comes with many advantages
first one is asp.net core is fast and
open source
if you compare that to the
traditional.net applications that have
been quite a few benchmarks and it is
very fast when you compare that to web
forms or even dotnet mvc
net core is also cross-platform
the classic.net was tied to iis and
windows
but since the.net core is rewritten it
has removed that dependency with net
core
we also have a built-in support for
dependency injection which saves a lot
of time and it is extremely helpful
once you get used with using dependency
injection you cannot imagine your
application without that
with any programming language it is
critical that the new updates are the
new version that are released they
should be easily upgradable
and that is one of the feature with dot
net core
when a new version is released updating
to that new version does not have ground
breaking changes
because of that you can always keep up
with the new versions
dot net code is also cloud friendly
when the dot net code was being written
cloud architecture was kept in mind and
because of that it is completely
compatible with all of the cloud
components
and lastly when it comes to performance
dotnet code exceeds all of the previous
versions and even the new versions in
dot net core that are being released
they supersede the previous version
the code actually gets more optimized
that results into improved performance
the asp.net core compiler will
eventually optimize the entire code
whenever the code is recomposed using
the.net core framework
dot net core's actual performance is
multiple times than any of the
frameworks previous implementation
because of that it is clear that
microsoft has a long long-term plan with
dotnet code technology
so with that brief overview let's
continue our learning in the next video
in this video before we take a look at
the other files i will introduce you to
a new concept which is dependency
injection
asp.net core implements a simple
built-in dependency injection
container dependency injection is an
integral part of the asp.net core
architecture
dot net core injects objects of
dependency classes through constructor
by using the built-in ioc container
before i show you what advantages
dependency injection brings
let's see a scenario where there is no
dependency injection
in a typical application let's say we
have three pages right now and we have
some common functionality that we want
to use across all the three pages
like let's say we want to send emails
and we want to access our database in
all the three pages that we have
now let's imagine that on these three
pages we need to access the database
first
so what we will do is we will create the
object for database classes on all the
three pages we will have to open that
connection we will have to do the
database operation and then we will have
to close the connection in all the
places
to do the same and create object for
email implementation that we have in all
the three pages
so you can see this is lot of duplicate
code
on top of that what happens in future if
you change the implementation of how you
access the database or email
based on the current configuration you
might have to make that change in all of
the three pages
which is a big mess because right now
it's three pages down the line it could
be 30 or 300 pages
another issue here is that on each page
you will deal with creating the object
managing them as well as disposing them
and that will be a time consuming effort
when we have to do that in all the pages
so that being said what is a solution to
avoid all of this and get an optimal
architecture
the answer to all of that is dependency
injection
first let me show how the scenario would
look like again we will have the three
pages and we will have email and
database functionality
these are the common things that we had
before as well
but now we will have something special
which is dependency injection container
so as you can see we have got our
dependency injection container that will
have an i email and an itb interface and
its implementation
so inside our container we have the
implementation of the i email interface
and the itb interface
when any page will need access to these
functionalities it will just ask the
dependency injection container to create
an object of this functionality
and directly give page an object to use
so inside the page we will actually be
using an interface and then dependency
injection does all its magic of passing
the object when the website needs it
that way we do not have to deal with
creating the object disposing or
managing that object inside our pages
our pages will look very clean with just
the interface
all the instance and implementation will
be done by dependency injection
container
now in future if you want to change or
replace the email class you do not have
to make any changes in the pages
all you have to do is just change the
implementation inside the email class
and since we are registering that in the
container
next time when we build the project it
will take the new implementation
so you can see we only have to change in
one place now
that is one of the main advantage that
comes with dependency injection
now in order to use dependency injection
you can use many third-party tools
but with dot net core we have a built-in
dependency injection container and that
has its own advantages
so i hope with that you have a short
overview of how dependency injection is
helpful
first thing that we have to do is we
need to create our project
i will be using visual studio 2022
here we have the recent projects on the
left and on the right hand side we will
get started we want to start by creating
a new project
so we will click that
and it will display all of the templates
you can either navigate and try to find
the template or you can just search here
for model
views and controller
as soon as you type that you see there
are two templates that are available
right here
we will be using the asp.net core with
c-sharp language we do not want the
other language
so select the c-sharp language or
asp.net code web app and we have model
views and controller
let's hit the next button and we have
few more options that we have to
configure
before writing the project name we can
give our solution a meaningful name
so let's say we are making our project
for bulky book
and in there you can have multiple
projects like there can be data access
layer that can be business layer that
can be web layer and so on
so solution name we can keep that as
bulky book
and then the project name let's call
this bulky book
web
that way you can keep the project name
and the solution name separated
let me change the location to where i
want to save on my computer and we will
hit next button
final thing that we have to select here
is the framework version
we will be using dotnet 6 so we will
select that in the first option next we
have authentication time
when you click the authentication
drop-down there are individual users
account microsoft identity platform and
windows
right now we want to keep things simple
and understand the basic folder
structures of when an empty.net core mvc
project is created
so we will select none inside the
authentication
we will keep the configure for https
selected we do not want to enable docker
right now because we do not want to work
with the containers
with this configuration let's create our
project
it will take a while but it will create
the project and it will load all of the
files and folders
great so once the project is created it
will load the complete view of visual
studio
on the left side here we have the main
panel where we will be coding everything
and on the right side we have solution
explorer git changes if we want to
commit and some properties
now by mistake if you close the solution
explorer here do not panic
you can open it back up by going to
views here and we have the first option
which is solution explorer
with that in place let's continue from
the next video
now that our project has been created
let's take a look at the files and
folders that we have by default
the first thing that we should take a
look at is the project file
in order to access the project file you
will right click on the project name not
the solution we have our project with
the website icon here
if you right click there we have the
edit project file
when you open that up you will see view
configuration right here
the first section here defines what is
the target framework that we are using
we are using dotnet 6 so you can see
that right here
the next important thing inside this
file is the item group
item group will contain all the nuget
packages that we are using in the
project
we selected the runtime compilation and
that's why that package has been
installed
in future we will be installing more
packages when we connect to database use
entity framework code and so on
so in that case when we add nuget
packages to our project a new entry will
be made inside the cs broach file or the
project file
now usually you do not work with the
project file but it is always good to
know that we have all the packages and
the references listed in the project
file if in case you need to access that
so that covers our first file which is
the cs branch or the project file
now that we have seen the project file
the next thing that i want to show you
is we have dependencies here and we can
see the packages that we saw previously
inside the project file will be
installed right here
we will be adding more packages down the
road
but the next folder that we have is the
properties folder and inside there we
have launch settings.json
in here we have the different profiles
using which we can run our application
like you can see inside the profiles we
have a bulky book web profile and we
have an iis express profile
if we use the iis express profile we
know the port number that will be used
here is explicitly defined
if we use the bulky book web
in that case it will use 5000 and 5001
based on https or http
the bulky bookweb is the default type
what this will do is it will run a
dotnet command line and that will
trigger the application
so if you try to run this directly with
bulky book web
you will first see a command prompt
and then it will launch the website on
port 5001
you can see inside the logs it is
displaying all of that
so that is one way or one profile
to run our application
if you hover on this down arrow you will
see there is another profile which is
iis express and that is the name that we
have in launch settings
if you run with iis express it will use
the port number right here for the ssl
so let me run that and show that as well
great you can see it runs on the
different port that is defined right
here
so the default behavior is using the
bulky book web profile but we will be
changing that and using iis later on
so that was a brief overview on
launchsettings.json
after that the next folder that you see
here is the www
root folder
if you expand that you will see all the
static files of your project
so any static files like css javascript
images or any libraries everything will
go inside the www root folder
the www root folder will not have any c
sharp files
this folder is only meant to serve the
static files of our application
so we will be using the static folder
extensively throughout the course when
we are adding some js or some images or
any other libraries
the www root folder will be the root
folder of your application
so always remember if you ever have to
add any static file it will always go
inside the www
root folder
then we have the folders for controllers
models and view i will get back to them
in a couple of videos but the file after
that is appsettings.json
this is the file in which we will be
adding all of the connection strings and
secrets of our application
like you might have some api keys you
might have some send grid keys you have
stripe payment keys
any of the static secret keys that you
want to save we will be storing them
inside appsettings.json
if you expand this app settings you will
notice that we have
appsettings.development.json
so you can create new json files and it
will automatically bundle them inside
appsettings.json
like if you create for another
environment appsettings.staging.json
then you can have
appsettings.production.json
all of them will be bundled in one
umbrella
and then based on the environment
variable you can configure it to use the
different app settings file
because connection string for a database
in development will be different if you
compare that to staging preview or
production
so that way you can go into those
configuration
we will be using just appsettings.json
right now because we will be working
with the localhost
also in production there are multiple
ways of saving secrets like you can add
them to azure storage world and much
more
but that is beyond the scope of this
course to get started you need to
remember all of your application secrets
must be inside
settings.json and not directly inside
any of your cs or class files
we will come back to this file in the
later videos and we will add our
connection string
now the last file that we want to take a
look at is program.c
let's do that in the next video
next we have program.cs
this is the file that will be
responsible for running the application
once we open program.cs you can see we
have a variable builder
where the
webapplication.createbuilder is passed
with the built-in arguments
when you run with the.net command you
can pass custom arguments here if you
want
with that it will configure the
application and it will create the web
application builder object
now in the previous video we saw that we
can use dependency injection with dotnet
core
when we want to register anything with
our dependency injection container we
will be doing that right here
so let's say if we want to register our
database or email or anything else
we will have to do that between the
builder and before we call build on that
builder object
so right here we are just adding one
service to the container which is
builder dot
dot controllers with views
we are adding this service to the
container because we are using mvc
application for our project
if you were using razer pages then the
service will be different
now in the future videos when we
configure database in our project and we
add that to dependency injection we will
be adding a new service here in our
container or db
context if you are working with any
version prior to dotnet 6 or even some
of the initial preview versions of
dotnet 6
then this file was divided into a
separate startup.cs class file and the
services that we add to container were
inside a method configure services and
everything from line 9 onwards was
inside a configure method
so what we have on the top is we will be
adding services to our container
then we need to configure request
pipeline and that pipeline will be
configured from the highlighted section
you might be wondering what is this
pipeline
the pipeline specifies how application
should respond to a web request
when your application receives a request
from the browser the request goes back
and forth through the pipeline let me
switch to the presentation here
we have different browsers here and then
we have a pipeline
the pipeline specifies how application
should respond to a request that is
received when your application receives
a request from the browser the request
goes through the pipeline
in the pipeline you can add items that
you want
pipeline is made up of different
middlewares and mvc is a type of
middleware itself
so if we want an application to be built
using mvc we have to add that middleware
other example could be authentication
middleware authorization middleware and
so on
what exactly happens is when your
request will go through each of the
middleware it gets modified by them and
eventually it is passed to the next
middleware if that is the last
middleware in the pipeline the response
is returned back to the server
let's take a look at the few middlewares
that we have in our application
let me switch back to the code here and
you can see in the pipeline first we are
checking if it is development or not in
the environment
if it is then we are adding the use
developer exception page that will show
you user friendly exceptions so that you
can debug and solve them but if it is
not development then we are just
redirecting them to an error page
the next middleware is https redirection
and then we have a middleware to use our
static files that are defined in www
root folder
we also have a routing middleware and we
have authorization middleware
and we add authentication to our project
we will have to add a new middleware
inside the program.cs as well
then we are using a map controller route
that will map the different pattern that
we have for mvc
based on this routing it will be able to
redirect our request to the
corresponding controllers and action
then you should always keep in mind that
order of pipeline is extremely important
the way you write middlewares in the
pipeline that is exactly how the request
will be passed
so first routing will be done then it
checks for authorization and so on
so in this scenario if you want to use
authentication to your pipeline we have
a middleware which is app.use
authentication
but if you do this then it won't work
because authentication middleware should
always come before you authorize a user
because you only authorize a user that
is authenticated
that is the basic fundamentals of
authentication and authorization
so if you place the pipeline in some
different order
that will break things
inside the endpoints here you can see we
have a controller name an action name
and some id
this controller route will make more
sense when we understand routing in the
next video
let me show you more details on how
routing works
i won't be running the application to
show you that but i want to walk you
through some theory you can see when it
comes to routing in mvc application we
have controllers and we have actions
before we explore the routing let me
walk you through the main components of
an mvc application
which is models views and controller
let me switch back to the presentation
and give you a brief overview
now if you remember we had three folders
for models views and controllers and
that is what mbc stands for
the first thing in mvc is model which
represents shape of the data
a class in c sharp is used to describe a
model
the model component corresponds to all
the data related logic that user works
with
let's say inside your application you
have a table that stores all the
category or all the product details
then that product will be a model itself
model basically represents all the data
in your application
it can be a table that you are storing
inside sql server or it can be a model
which will be a combination of multiple
tables and so on
this model can either represent the data
that is being transferred between views
and controllers or any business related
data model that will represent all the
tables of the database
so if you have 10 tables in your
database we will have at least 10 models
that corresponds to them
there is also more complexity but we
will go into those details later on
right now you can think of all the
tables in your database will be a class
file which will be a model
then all the properties of that class
file will be the columns of the table
that is a simple relation that you can
think of right now
then we have view in an mvc which is the
user interface
view can be thought of html and css that
you write to make things fancy and
beautiful
whatever you see on the website with
your eyes is basically the view that is
being displayed to you
but now you need to think of what
happens if in a website you have a
button and you click that button
what happens is that view will interact
with your model to display some other
data
but view does not interact directly with
the models
for that we have something known as
controller
controller acts as an interface between
model and view to process all the
business logic and incoming request
so controller acts as an interface
between model and view to process all
the business logic
and it manipulates the data using model
and interacts with the view to render
the final output
this is just a brief overview of how
model views and controller works
so let's say if a user clicks on a
button controller is the first thing
that will receive that request
then controller will have lots of action
methods
based on those action methods controller
will redirect this request to one of the
action method and controller will use
the model it will fetch all the data
that it needs to display inside the view
once the view is rendered it will pass
all of that to the controller and
controller will then pass a response
which will be sent back and the user
will finally be able to see the page
so you can see controller can be treated
as heart of your application
that is where we will have all the logic
of your application and it is the one
which will be interacting with models
and views
so with that in place now you see that
the request first comes to the
controller and its action methods
so with that general idea if we go back
you can see inside the map controller
route we have a pattern where we define
a controller and an action method
so here we are saying that the default
if nothing is provided it should go to
the home controller and it should call
the index action method
but that is a 10 000 feet overview
let's take a look at routing little more
with some theory
before we see routing in action let's
see routing with some examples
you can see here we have a general
pattern of routing
the first thing highlighted in blue here
is the domain of the url
when we run on the local computer you
will have a local host and a port number
whatever is after that port number will
be the route that we want to use when we
are calling a page to be loaded
in the first example you see we have
something called as category then we
have an index and some number
when we are working with mvc after our
port number or domain whatever is the
first thing that we have will be the
name of the controller
then the next forward slash after that
will be the action of the controller and
after that if you have something that
will be the id
this is the pattern of routing with mvc
if we go back to the application you can
see the same format right here
first we have the controller name then
forward slash we have an action name
then forward slash we have the id
that corresponds with the request that
we have here
keep in mind that id is an optional
field
controller and action are not optional
but if they are not defined we have set
a default route that if there is no
controller and action you can use home
controller and index action as the
default route
because of that we have our home
controller and we also have the index
action which i will show you
before we dive into those details based
on the understanding that we have here i
have given some sample url
i want you to try to find out what will
be the controller action and id based on
this url
again remember if controller is not
defined default one that we have in our
application
is let's go back the home controller and
if the action is not defined that will
be index action
so based on that the first url that we
have the controller name is category the
action is index and we do not have any
id
for the next one we have controller name
as category we do not have any action
so index will be the default action
and finally id is null
next what we have for the third one we
have controller as category action as
added and id as three
the last one we have controller product
action details and we have id as three
so with that if you get a url now you
can identify what is the controller name
what is the action name and if there is
an id or not
so with that brief understanding of
routing let's actually run our
application see routing in action in the
next video
now we want to understand routing in mvc
this is one of the tricky topics that i
had when i first started learning mvc
so i want to make sure that you get
familiar with the routing
before we see the complete routing in
action let me walk you through the three
folders that we have
we have a folder for controller we have
a folder for models and we have a folder
for views
by default we have a home controller
that has been created
models will be all the data related
models that we want in the project
so let's say if you are dealing with
products that you want to display on the
page you will have a product model and
we will be using that model in
controller and views right now you can
just think of models as tables that you
want in your database
if you want a product table you will
have a product model
that is not always the case but we will
explore models later on
the main thing that we want to work on
is understanding controllers and views
controller is the heart of the
application at the same time views is
what will be displayed on the screen
when user is looking at the page
now the way navigation works is when we
have a home controller all of the views
or ui pages that are displayed with the
home controller will be placed inside
the same folder name as the controller
name
so you can see they have also created a
home folder by default
there is also a convention with the
naming of controllers it should always
end with the keyword of controller that
is how the application will know that
this is a controller
if we expand our home controller you
will see some code right here
we have a class with the name of home
controller and it implements the default
or the base class of controller
and right here we are registering the
logger using dependency injection
do not go into that detail right now i
will explain dependency injection in
much detail
but for now to understand routing you
can see we have two action methods
inside controllers you can have multiple
action method
if we go back to the url here you can
notice that we have the controller name
and action name
if the url was forward slash home
forward slash privacy then it will go to
home controller look for a privacy
action method and it will load the
content that we have here
the return type for an action method is
i action result because i action result
is an abstraction for multiple return
type
it can return a view it can redirect to
some action method or it can redirect a
page and much more then i said that if
the url is home forward slash index it
will return the view that we have
defined here
now you might be thinking that where is
this view we are talking about
that view will be inside the views
folder
the way it finds or maps the view for
this index action method is inside the
views folder it will look for the name
of the controller which is home
controller so we have that folder
inside there we will have a view with
the name of this action method and it is
index action method
so that will be mapped to this
particular view
if we open that view we have some html
and bootstrap classes so here nothing
fancy is going on we are just displaying
some text
so let's run our application and see
routing in action
right now it will run in the command
prompt window
and once that is done it will run the
website on port 5001
in the url right now nothing is present
what should happen if there are no
controllers and actions in the url
we defined that inside the program.cs
we said if nothing is present default
that to home controller and index action
method
so what we see on the screen is from the
home controller index action method
to confirm that if you go to the home
controller you can add a debugging point
by clicking anywhere on the window
what that will do is when it hits this
controller this will be yellow
so if we go back and if we refresh the
page you can see it hits our breakpoint
here
so that means if nothing is present in
the url it is calling the home
controller index action method
let me also add a debugging point inside
the privacy action method
so we will hit continue here and the
request goes back
so we will hit continue and then here we
have return view that will find out the
view that is associated and it will
display that on the page
if you right click on the view here you
have link to go to the view if you click
there it will automatically redirect you
to the index view because it knows it
has to find the home folder inside there
there will be an index view
this is how controllers and views are
associated
so if we go back to the application
while this is running we have the
privacy tab here and you can see on the
bottom right the url that it will go to
is home forward slash
privacy so what will be the controller
name
controller name will be home and action
name will be privacy
so it will go to the home controller it
will go to the privacy action method and
it will return the view the view is
inside home we have privacy and it
should display this particular paragraph
let's go back and hit that
it hits our debugging point that is
great let's continue
and it displays the privacy policy
so that is perfect with this you can see
how routing is working in action with
mvc
based on the url you have to define the
controller name and action name it goes
to the controller finds out that action
method and it returns view based on the
view that you have defined inside the
views
folder now if this is too much right now
do not worry just understand the basics
that i have taught you in this video but
as we proceed with the course routing
will make much more sense
and if this is too much for you do not
worry you are not alone when i was
learning mvc about 10 years ago at that
time i had a very hard time trying to
understand this since i was coming from
the web form world where we just have
code behind files
so as we program this more it will get
much more familiar and you will love the
way it works
so let's continue from the next video
now that we have seen the basic
controllers and views and how the
interaction works with routing i want to
walk you through the basic views that
are available with our project
we saw the home folder inside views that
corresponds to the views of the home
controller
but on top of that we have something
called a shared
shared folder is used for partial views
and partial views are similar to user
components if you are coming from
classic c sharp
so it's basically a view that you can
call within a view in multiple places in
your application
along with that we have a special
partial view which is underscored layout
and this underscored layout is the
default master page of your application
so if you open that up you can see we
have some styling on the top here we
have a header right here and we have a
div where we render the body
since this is the master page so
whatever we display inside the other
views it will use this underscore layout
as the default master page
so inside index when we are displaying
this content it was displaying that with
the navigation on the top
we also have a footer here and we have
some common javascript that we want
across the application
we have the main html and body tag and
we have head right here where we are
adding the styling
we will be updating this in future
videos whenever we want to add some css
and js globally this is the place where
we will be adding that
next we have a validation scripts
partial and this is a partial view where
we are just adding scripts for some
validations
wherever in some views let's say in
index view we want to use validations
then we will include this partial view
on that page
so that way we do not have to write
those script tags we will just include
this partial view and that will be
included
we also have an error partial view that
will be used to display the errors if
you encounter in the application
we will be adding more partial views as
we proceed with the course so do not
worry but remember shared folder will
contain all the partial views and
underscored layout is the master page of
your application
while the application is running if i
switch back quickly you can see on the
privacy page we have the header here we
have the footer here and we have the
body
so where we have this render body at
that place whatever we had inside the
privacy these two lines are being
displayed
so i hope that makes sense
then we have something called as
underscore view import and underscore
view start
let me open the view import first and we
have the global namespace right here
so inside your application let's say you
want to access some namespace in all of
the pages
if you add that using statement here it
will be accessible across all the pages
controllers and classes in your project
that way you do not have to type this
namespace every time
we will see that in action as we proceed
with the course
but one important thing that you see
here is tag helpers
helpers are bindings that are provided
by the.net core team that looks like
html tags but they are special tags that
are adopted by the microsoft team from
other languages after looking at the
success like angular and react
i will show you one example quickly here
in the underscored layout if we go back
to our application we click on privacy
you see it builds the url home and
privacy
here we know that home is controller and
action name is privacy
so how do you think this link is
provided on this navigation
it is provided using a special tag
helper let me expand the header here and
you can see we have an anchor tag and
then we have tag helpers for asp
controller and asp action
tag helpers will start with the prefix
of asp.hyphen
and then the name
so here we have a tag helper which says
asp controller and then we define the
controller name for routing and in that
controller what action name should be
called so that is asp action
do not worry about the asp areas for now
we will be using lots of tag helpers
that are provided by the dot net team in
future
but tag helpers have been included in
the project and we define them globally
inside the view imports file
the last file inside the views folder is
the view start
this file will define what is the
default master page for your application
inside privacy you see we have not
defined what will be the master page but
it is by default using underscore layout
because that is what has been defined
inside the view start file
if you want to explicitly define a
master page for privacy which is
different you can do that directly by
defining that on the top
and that will take preference over what
is defined in view start
but view start will have the default
master page for the application
now i know this section was a little bit
lengthy but this overview was critical
when it comes to understanding the
default views that have been provided
in this video let's take a look at tag
helpers
tag helpers are brand new to asp.net
core
microsoft looked at the success around
libraries like angular react and decided
that implementing an angular directive
like experience in the new asp.net was
so important to the adoption of dot net
core that they decided to create tag
helpers from grounds up
even though there are similarities
between angular directives and tag
helpers there is a major difference
tag helpers are for server-side
rendering while the angularjs directives
are all about client-side rendering
if you have worked with older versions
of net core we had something called as
html helpers
they are still around but tag helpers
are being modern with the tag like
approach so it's much user friendly
tag helpers are very focused around the
html element and are much more natural
to use as compared to html helpers
we will be working with tag helpers many
time in the application
but to just give you a brief overview
you can see in the first tab here we
have html helpers and tag helpers
simplifies all of them because we can
use the existing label tag and we will
just add a tag helper asp4 and we will
bind that to a model
we have same tag helper right here as
well
then in the last example here i am
displaying tag helpers where previously
we were using html dot begin form
and now within the same form tag we have
the tag helpers of where it should be
posted
so you can see things are getting much
more simpler when we are using tag
helpers
that being said if you are coming to net
brand new and you have never worked with
html helpers this is even better
you do not have to worry about the old
syntax and what is different
we will be working with tag helpers in
the upcoming videos but i just wanted to
give you a brief snippet of what tag
helpers are and how they look like when
we are using the same tags we just use
the asp hyphen and then the tag helper
name
that being said we will explore all of
this in much more details in the
upcoming videos
when you will be working with a.net core
application you will see the return type
of action result
and it does not matter if you are using
an mvc application or a razer page
application
in both the cases you can see we have i
action result
in mvc we are returning back view in
this example and in razer page page
handler we are returning back to the
page
but the return type is i action result
i action result is a generic type that
implements all of the other return types
now if you want to be explicit about the
return type in both of these cases then
that would look something like this
if the return type is view you can write
view result but in razer pages when we
return back to page you can write page
result
so now what is the advantage of i action
result
so first let's understand some theory
so action result is a pattern class for
many of the derived classes that have
associated helpers
the i action result return type is
appropriate when multiple action results
return type are possible in an action
let's take a look at some of the helpers
and action result
so first let's take a look at what is
there in razer pages
a racer page can return content file not
found page a partial result and redirect
to different pages
for all of them we have return types
like content result file content result
not found result page result partial
result and so on
if we are working with an mvc
application we can return back views
partial views we can redirect to action
return json and so on
so if you are returning any one of these
then you can use the individual return
types for result based on the helper
method
but what if you were returning something
like this
right here in mvc you can see we are
returning if true let's imagine there
was some condition here based on that if
that condition is true you want to
redirect to action
else you want to return to view
this time you cannot have two different
return types
if you use view result here return view
is working but redirect to action will
throw error
similarly if you use redirect to action
result then redirect to action works but
return view
will give you error
if you are working on razer pages and
you have the same situation if you use
page wizard then return page will work
but redirect to page will fail
and if you use redirect to page result
then return page will fail
so what is the solution to all of this
the solution is to use i action result
in both the places because this is a
parent class so it does not care which
of its implementation is being returned
it will be able to handle all of them
so that is a brief overview on how
action result will help us with the
return type from action method in mvc
application
or page handlers in a razor page
application
now that the project has been created
there are few files and folder
structures right here
we will go into all of these files and
folder structure in the upcoming videos
but right now inside the views folder we
have home and inside there we have
index.cshtml
this is the default home page of our
application
so if i open this up you will see there
is some welcome text here and a
paragraph which is inside a div tag
let's run our application and see what
is the output
it loads up the default page of the
website where we have the project name
here a home page and a privacy page
you can see on the home page we have
some text right here
and that html is exactly same as what we
see inside the index dot cs html
i do not want to go into much technical
details but let's say you are making
some changes inside your view if you
save that you go back to the application
and if you refresh here you directly see
the changes right here
if you notice in visual studio 2022
there is this icon which is for hot
reload
this is a great capability that has been
added with dot net syncs
if this does not refresh and reload for
you you can go here and make sure the
hot reload on file save is enabled
what that will do is whenever you make
some change here and you save if you go
back and refresh
you can see the change is being
reflected in the ui
this is very helpful when you are
designing something with mvc or razer
application
but if you notice the first time you had
to manually come to the page and refresh
and after that the hot reload
automatically works
so i wanted to walk you through that
advantage
now if you were working with an
application which is not in dot net 6
then you will have to right click on the
project and you will have to add a new
git package by clicking the manage nuget
package
you will search for a package runtime
compilation and you can see we have
microsoft.asp.netcode.mvc.razer.runtime
this package was needed before so you
can hit the install button to add that
to our project
even though that is not needed here i
still want to add that
then you will have to go to program.cs
and right here we only have add
controllers with view
when you add razer pages you will add
builder dot services dot ad racer pages
and on there you will have to enable the
ad raiser runtime compilation
but because of hot reload and the magic
that we have this is no longer required
so in the future videos when we will be
adding the razer pages i also add the
razer runtime compilation because when
the video was originally recorded in dot
net 6 hard reload was still in testing
so that's why i have added the razer
runtime compilation down the road
but you can skip that and you will just
add the builder dot services
pages
so that's a brief overview that i wanted
to give you with the heart reload in dot
net 6.
that being said in the next video let's
first examine all the files and folder
structures that have been created here
when we work with any web project the
main piece or the heart of the
application is the data
and we need database to store our data
so we will be using sql server to create
a database and store all the data for
our website
with dotnet code you might have heard
about term called as entity framework
core as well
if not do not worry but entity framework
core is what we'll be using to create
database and we will be using the same
to perform all the data operations
so with dot net core you do not need
stored procedures or writing sql
statements in the code
entity framework is a smart editor that
will help us with all the data related
operations
that being said it does not mean that
you cannot use stored procedures
you can still use stored procedures if
you want
but typically with mvc application
entity framework core is used to
manipulate the data layer
we will go into those details in the
upcoming videos but right now we first
need to create our model
model will basically resemble a table in
database
it is not always the case but whatever
tables you have in your database you
will need a corresponding model for the
code first migration
so inside the models folder we only have
error view model
let me create one more model here we
will right click there and we will add a
class file
we want to create a table for category
so we will call our model as category
and let's add that
it creates a public class file and it
places it inside the namespace of
bulkybookweb.models
that is just the location so it knows
that it is inside bulkybookweb models
folder that is the category class right
here
now inside this category class we need
to create all the properties that we
want for our table
we want to create id name and a display
order
so to start we can write prop and it is
a code snippet so once you type flop and
hit tab two times it will automatically
create a property
the id column we will keep that as
integer and i will call that as id
next property that we want to create
will be the name of the category that
will be a string so we will create that
we press prop again
we want the display order
now display order will be an integer
so let me add that
on top of that let's say for locking
purpose we want to create a datetime
property which will have the date on
when this category was created
so we will call this createdtime
now the createdatetime let's say we want
to set a default value to that so in
order to do that we can use equal to
sign and we can just assign the
datetime.now
like this
that way the default value will
automatically be assigned to the
createddatetime when we create an object
of this class
so perfect we have created our model and
then we want to push this model to our
database to create a table with these
four columns
but when we create a database table we
might want to add some more
configuration
like we might want to say that id is a
primary key and since it's an integer we
want to make that an identity column so
we do not have to populate that when we
create a row inside the new table that
we will create
we could also add a validation that name
is a required property and it should not
be now
if we had to write a sql statement we
could have done all of that by using
normal and identity in our sql script
but how will we do that using entity
framework
for that dotnet team has come up with
alternatives called as data annotation
so on the property where you want to
configure some more details we have
special attributes that you can use
let me walk you through them in the next
video
now we want to configure some of the
requirements that we have in a sql
script
like we want to make this id column an
identity column which will be the
primary key of this table in order to do
that we have a data annotation
or an attribute known as key
if you enter that you notice the red
squiggly lines
if you hover on that it will display an
error that key attribute could not be
found
that is because we have to add a using
statement
so you need to make sure your keyboard
is on the key and then if you press ctrl
dot it will display that you can add
using statement to resolve this
so we will press enter that will add the
using statement which has the data
annotation that we want
once this key annotation has been
applied it will tell entity framework
core that hey when you create a script
to create this table you need to make
sure that id is a primary key and it
should also be an identity column
it does all the configuration and
talking by itself
we just need to write one attribute and
everything will be done for us
pretty simple right
the next thing that we wanted to do is
we want to make sure that name is a
required property
so here we have another attribute which
is required
once you assign that when it creates the
script it will make sure that name is
not available property
now we have talked about these two but
there are more annotations that you can
do for validation
with this in place the initial iteration
of our model looks good
how do we create that in our database
now let's take a look at that in the
next video
we have added the data annotations and
we have created our model
we need to create a table and a database
inside sql server
so let me open up sql server management
studio
make sure you have that installed on
your machine because that is what we
will be using to play with the database
once the sql server management studio
opens up we will be using our local
database
now for some of the users it could be
localdb backward slash ms sql localdb
for others it could be just a dot
i have both of the server name
configured so i will use any one of them
and i will hit the connect button
as long as it is able to connect that
server name is what you will be using
inside your connection string
if you use something else then it won't
work
so i will be using dot
but on your end you need to check if dot
works you can use that or the local db
ms sql local db should also work
let's hit cancel here and if we expand
the databases you can see we have few
database here but i want to create a new
database for our
project so for that we have to create a
connection string inside our project
in order to store all of the secrets of
your application you will be doing that
inside the
appsettings.json file you can hard code
the connection string inside the class
file but that is a bad approach
appsettings.json file is the file where
you should have all the secrets that way
if you have to update anything in the
future you know it will be available
inside the appsettings.json file
and then you can create different app
settings for different environment
like if you have development staging
preview production you can create all of
those app settings and you can configure
to use that app settings when you deploy
the application
that way based on your environment name
you can use different app settings or
different database and so on
we will be working directly in
appsettings.json
and that should work with the local
development
so this is a simple json file now how
will we add a new connection string in
here
as you can see it is just a dictionary
with string key and value pairs
what you have inside logging is known as
a block where inside the logging block
we have another block of log level and
that has three key value pairs
so we can either create a block or we
can directly configure the connection
string
now the dotnet team thought that
connection string is very common and
almost all of the projects will have a
connection string that is why they have
created a default block for connection
string that we can use if we want
you can use something else but you can
also use the default block name that
they have given
if you see it is automatically
suggesting me that block name which is
connection strings
we can use something else but i want you
guys to use the exact same name for now
and i will also tell you the reason
behind that in the upcoming videos
so inside this block we will have a key
value name
so that key name you can use whatever
you want i will just use default
connection
you can use any name that you want for
the key right here and we need to paste
or enter a connection string within the
double quotes on the right side so the
first parameter here will be the server
name i am using dot so that is what i
will write if you are using a different
server name like if we go back to sql
server
and if you were using the ms sql local
db to connect i want you guys to copy
this go back to the application
and paste that here i am using the local
server with the dot so that is what i
will use and then we need the next
parameter
if you have to separate anything in a
connection string we will use a
semicolon the next property that we have
is the database name let's call this
bulky
then after that we want to set the
trusted connection flag to be true
make sure there is no spelling mistake
here
and that is all that we want to
configure in the connection string
you can make it more complicated but we
will keep things pretty simple
we have a database name that we want to
create inside this particular server
that we are able to connect in sql
server and the trusted connection is
true that way when we connect here we
can just use windows authentication
if you have a user id and password then
you can use the different settings in
connection string
i will be using the default trusted
connection
so with this we are using a special
block that is available with the name of
connection string in there we have a key
of default connection and value has the
connection string
now how can we use this connection
string to actually create the database
and create our category table inside the
database
let's do that in the next video
we need to tell our application that we
will be using sql server and you have to
use this connection string to establish
the connection with sql server
for that we will be using entity
framework core and we will have to
create an object of the db context
using that db context we will be able to
make connection to the database
so how do we do that
it is best to create a new folder for
all the data related changes
so here let me create a new folder with
the name of data
inside there we will create our db
context
we will create a class here
and i will call that application
db
context
you can use any name that you want here
but i'm using db context so that it's
easy to identify
let's add that class file
now we need to inherit this class file
from the db context that is inside
entity framework core
in our project we have not added entity
framework code right now
so there are two ways to add that
we know that this will inherit from the
db context so we can type that and you
will see the red squiggly lines
on there if you press ctrl dot inside
the suggestions it will display that you
can install a package microsoft dot
entity framework core
that will automatically find and install
the latest version
if you want to do that yourself you can
right click on the project and you can
select manage nuget packages or you can
go to tools we have no get package
manager and we can open up manage nuget
packages for solution
here you will have to go to the browse
tab to see all the new get packages that
are available
now right now i'm using dot net 6 with
the preview version so i have checked
the include pre-release right here
the package that we are looking for is
entity framework core
let's press enter and the first package
is microsoft dot entity framework or
we are using the preview 7 so let me
select that and we will install that
once that is installed if we go back to
our application db context and now if we
press ctrl dot here
it will tell us that we just have to add
the using statement since we have
already installed the package
so we will add the using statement for
our db context
once we do that then there is one line
of configuration that we have to do
inside the constructor of this class
file
you can think of that as the general
syntax that is needed to establish the
connection with entity framework
so first we need to create a constructor
you can type ctor and press tab twice
you can see it is a code snippet for
constructor
so once you press tab twice it should
automatically create the constructor
we just have to write some parameters
here because when we get the db context
we need to pass that on to the base
class which is tb context
so here we will have to configure the db
context options on the class that we are
on right now which is application db
context we can paste that here and i
will call this options
so here we are saying that in the
constructor here we will receive some
options
and those options we just have to pass
to the base class which is db context
this is a general setup that you have to
do
that will configure rtb context
now once you configure our db context we
still have one main feature
we still have to create our category
table inside the database
so whatever models that you have to
create inside the database you will have
to create a db set inside the
application db context the file that we
are currently working on
now how do you create a db set
that is pretty simple we will say public
db set here and we need to write the
model name
that model name is category and once you
write that you again see the red
squiggly lines
that is because it cannot find anything
with the name of category in the same
file we need to add the using statement
to tell it that category is inside the
models folder
so if you press ctrl dot we have that
using statement
let's add that and the next parameter
here is the table name
so if you call this categories then
inside database the table that will be
created will be called as categories and
not category
so that looks good and we will add the
getter and setter
that's all that we had to do to create
the category table
what this will do is it will create a
category table with the name of
categories and it will have four columns
that we have wrote inside the category
model
when it creates that table it will make
sure that id is an identity column and
name is a required field as well
so you can see it is doing all the
configuration by writing just few lines
of code
now when you are working with entity
framework core there are two models one
is code first and one is database first
what we are doing is code first because
here we are writing the code of our
model and based on that model we will be
creating the database
so that is the code first approach
database first approach will be
something where database is already
created and based off that database you
will be scaffolding models
i personally am a big fan of code first
and that is what i have been using in
all of my production application because
i do not come from a dba management
point of view i am more of a full stack
developer who works with the code
so if entity framework code will manage
database for us i will be very happy
with that approach
so with that we have added our dbseg for
the category table
but we are missing one small
configuration
our application still does not know that
it has to use the connection string that
we wrote in app settings
and it still does not know that it has
to use application db context to create
a db context and that it has to work
with sql server
so let's see how we can pull everything
together in the next video
we just need to tell our application
that it has to use the db context which
is inside application db context and
then it has to use a sql server using
the connection string that we defined
inside the appsettings.json
we will tell our application to do that
insideprogram.cs
where we configure the services that our
application will use
so here we have the comments to add the
services to the container
make sure you always do that before you
build the builder
so right here we want to add a new
service so on builder dot services the
service that we want to add is db
context
so you can see we have dot add db
context and that expects a class file
the class file that we are using for db
context is the application db context
if you press ctrl dot we will just have
to add the using statement to the data
folder
now when we configure this db context if
we go back to the application db context
right here we are passing the options
and we are sending those options to the
base class
so inside options we have to configure
use of sql server and connection string
so here we will say options
goes to this is just the syntax we will
say options dot
there is a method with the name of use
sql server
but it will not be available like that
even if you press ctrl dot it will not
give you the package name that you have
to add
so for that we will have to go back to
the manage nuget packages and we will
have to install a package which is sql
server with entity framework core
which is microsoft
dot entity framework core dot sql server
make sure you are using the consistent
version
if one version of the package you are
using is preview 7 and other one is
preview 5 or even.net 5
then things won't work and you will run
into error message
so always make sure that you are using
the same version
let me install the sql server and we
will close the new bit packages
now if you press control dot you will
see the using statement using microsoft
dot entity framework core
we will add that and on this sql server
we have to write the connection string
so where exactly is our connection
string
that is inside app settings we used a
special block with the name of
connection strings
since we wrote our connection string
inside the special block theme that i
was talking about we can directly use
the key value here to extract the
connection string
let me copy this name
we will go back to our program.cs
and right here on builder.configuration
we have an existing method that is
provided which is getconnectionstring
inside this method we have to pass the
string name which is default connection
once you use that it will automatically
find the connection string and configure
our sql server
now this cat connection string is a
special method and this method will only
look for this default connection inside
a block with the name of connection
strings
if you named this connection strings 1
then it will not be able to find this
connection string because this method
will only look inside the block which is
connection strings
so that is why i said to name it exactly
the same
if you wanted to name it something else
we have different ways of getting that
but i do not want to go into those
details right now
so with this our db context will be
configured with the connection string
so all the configuration is done that
was needed for the db context
now we are on the final step where we
have to create database and then the
table inside sql server
let's take a look at that in the next
video
now that the program.cs has been
configured the next step that we have is
to actually create the database and the
table
when you are using entity framework code
first there are migrations that you have
to run using entity framework to push
the changes to database
it is not as complex as it sounds we
have done all the setup that is needed
in order to run the migration you will
go to tools nuget package manager and
this time you will select the package
manager console
the first thing that you have to do is
you have to add a migration
migration is basically keeping a track
of all the db changes that are needed
and once that migration is created you
push that migration to the database to
actually create the database or make
changes to your table
let's see what that is the command to
add a migration is add hyphen migration
and then we have to give our migration a
meaningful name
do not use any spaces when you are
writing the name
the name that i want to give to our
migration is add category to database
let's hit the add button and we see an
error message
the error is because when you run add
migration you have to add a new kit
package
you see the term add migration is not
recognized
i want you guys to copy this error and
try to find out what is the package that
is missing from google
i can give you the answer directly but i
want you guys to google what package is
required based on this error message
if you just copy that error and paste it
here you will see the very first and if
you scroll down you will see the package
name it is so simple just install
microsoft dot entity framework core dot
tools
that is the package that is required to
enable migrations in your project
whenever you face any error it is best
to just google that error that way you
can find the solution much easily and
much quicker
so let's go to our project manage nuget
packages
we will paste the package name
and we will install the same version
that we have in our project
perfect that is done we can close this i
can open up the package manager console
again
and i will run the same command one more
time
this time it should complete
successfully
and if you notice on the right hand side
here a new folder with the name of
migrations is created and there are two
files that got added
our migration file is the first one and
that is opened up on the screen as well
inside migrations we have two methods
one is up and one is down
the up method is what needs to happen
inside the migration and down is if
something goes down we need to roll back
the changes
so do not worry about the down right now
let's see what's happening inside the up
method
on the migration builder we have a
method with the name of create table
and it is creating the table with the
name of categories
that is the exact name that we defined
right here
so it will create a table with the name
of category and then that will have
columns
the first column will be the id column
which will be of the type integer and
nullable is false
since we said it is a key column it is
automatically making that an identity
column and incrementing that by one
every time
pretty smart right
the next thing is the name column and
you can see the nullable is falsier
if you did not add the required property
then nullable would be true
you will see that display order is also
nullable false but we did not add that
inside category
and the reason behind that is it is an
integer property and not a string
that is why nullable is false because
it's an integer
last we have the created datetime of the
type datetime2 and that looks good
if you see on the constraints it is also
adding a primary key on the id column
with a name
so migrations is exactly what we wanted
but can we take a look at the sql that
gets executed
no what entity framework code does is
based on this migrations it will create
an optimized version of the sql query
and it will automatically run that on
the database
you do not have to do anything with that
what you work with is just the models
you create a migration and you push that
to the database
so once you verify that migration is
looking good you can just run the
command update database and that will
push the migrations to database
we have an error here let me go to app
settings
and of course we do this will not be
colon this will be equal to right here
and they are separated by a semicolon
that was my bad we will go back to the
package manager and you can also see the
error set server and colon was not
supported because it should be equal to
let's update the database one more time
perfect the migrations were completed
but what actually happened is first it
will connect to the server it will check
is there a database with the name of
monkey there won't be anything right now
so it will create that database first
and then the migrations here it will
convert them to sql and execute them on
our database
so if we go back now if we refresh the
database you will see the new database
with the name of bulky and if you open
the tables there will be two tables
let's examine the columns inside the
categories table
it should have four columns and that
looks great
now what is inside the ef migrations if
you do the select top thousand entity
framework code keeps a track of which
migrations have been applied so next
time when you run the update database it
will not apply the same migration it
will only apply the migrations that have
not been applied on this database
entity framework code is pretty smart
with all the configuration and tracking
that it needs to do
so with that using entity framework core
we have created our database and we have
added our table based on the model
inside our main project
so with that let me continue in the next
video
now before we work on anything else let
me run the project
right now it is running on port 5001 let
me change that so that the command
prompt is not opened every time we can
just run that using iis profile by
clicking here
that way it won't run on the port 5001
it will get the new port that is defined
in the project config
i'm getting an error that i'll have to
open visual studio under an admin
account so let me do that real quick
we will open the project again
we have the iis express here let's try
to run it this time
and perfect so we have home and privacy
but both of these pages are inside the
home controller
now in category we will be creating
editing and deleting category
so for that rather than working on the
home controller let's create a new
controller for our category
so inside the controllers folder we will
right click add a controller
and we have few options here we will go
with the empty controller to keep things
very simple and start from scratch
i will call that as category controller
now when you name a controller make sure
that you append controller at the end
that is a required field whatever name
you want must come before the controller
so once you have that name we will click
the add button
perfect we get an empty controller
with index action method
our home controller also had the index
action method and our category
controller also has the index action
method
but the index action method in home
controller has a view that is inside the
home folder
our category action method does not have
a view right now
you can add the view in two ways
first you can create a folder with the
name of controller which is category
inside the views and then you can add
index view inside there
or if you want to do that directly from
the controller you can just right click
on the action
and you have add view
we will be selecting the razer view here
let's hit the add button
now when you add a razer view there are
a few configuration that you have to do
first what will be the name of the view
we will give that the same name as the
action method which is index
then do you want to use any templates
when you create this view
if you hover here you can create a view
for create delete details edit and list
i do not want to go into those details
right now but we will come back to that
later on
if you change that then model and data
context class will be enabled
but we don't want to focus on that right
now we want to start scratch with an
empty template
next is a partial view
partial view is basically like user
controls in the web form
so it will be rendered inside some other
view so if you select a partial view the
layout page will not be used
because you do not need any master page
if you create a user component because
you will be calling that inside some
other view
we don't want to take a look at that
right now
let's keep it simple
next we will use the layout page
we want our view to use the default
master page
so if you keep it blank it will by
default use the layout that we have set
inside the view start which is
underscored layout
we want it to be consistent so that is
what we will be using
and we will hit the add button
it will scaffold few dependencies and
then it will create the view
if you had any errors while building the
project and if you try to scaffold that
will fail
it will ask you to resolve the errors
and only once your project is building
successfully you will be able to
scaffold the views
so perfect our view has been created and
let me call this index category
with that let's continue in the next
video
we want to display all the categories if
there are any in the table format inside
the index view
for that we will have to actually
retrieve all the category list from our
database inside the index action method
so let me open up the layout page right
here where we have two options of index
and the privacy page
rather than privacy let me display the
category right here
and in order to go to the index page how
can we navigate to this particular view
that was created
it is inside category controller and we
have index action method
so here to navigate we can define the
controller name is category
and the action method is
index
we are not using areas here so you can
keep that blank or you can also remove
them if you want
if you save this let's run the project
one more time and make sure we are able
to navigate to our action method
so we have category when we click there
perfect we see the index categories that
is what we have inside the view
so we are able to navigate there
successfully
now we need to retrieve all of the
categories from our database so let me
switch back to database and just for
dummy purpose let me edit the top 200
and let me add something here
so i have just created one dummy record
inside the table right now
i have created one dummy record inside
the table
let's go back and we want to retrieve
that inside the category controller
now i have said before that we will be
using entity framework or
and the main file that we have is the
application db context using that we can
access our database object
because inside that file we have the
categories table
so how can we create an object of this
application db context and use that to
call our database and table
that is the beauty of dependency
injection
we do not have to create an object of
this class
everything will be done for us because
we have configured that inside our
container we want to use this service
so because of dependency injection
we will not have to create its object we
can think that the object is already
there we just have to tell application
that please send me the object of
application db context
how do you request that
inside the controller you want the
application db context to work with
database
so i will first create a private read
only field which will be application db
context
and i will call that underscore tb
we will add the using statement there
and great
now we need to tell our application that
we need an implementation of this
application db context where the
connection to database is already made
and i can retrieve some records right
away
so for that you will have to use
constructor ctor tab tab
and here whatever is registered inside
the container you can access that
inside our container we have registered
application db context so inside the
constructor we can get an implementation
of that just like this
so this db will have all the
implementation of connection strings and
tables that are needed to retrieve the
data
so we will populate our local db object
with this implementation
so we'll say underscore tb is equal to
db
and then we can use this underscore db
to retrieve our categories
the syntax of that is very simple we
will create a var let me call this obj
category list
we will first access the underscore db
and on there we will have all the db set
the db set that we want to work on right
now is categories
and we want to convert it to a list and
retrieve that
so it will go to database it will
retrieve all of the categories it will
convert that to a list and it will
assign that inside the category list you
can see how beautiful this is you do not
have to write a select statement to
retrieve all the categories from the
table there is no sql coding required
you just have to write underscore tb dot
the db set name and that will retrieve
all the records you convert that to a
list and you assign that to a variable
now how do we test that this is working
we will add a debugging point by going
to this pan you see the red dots
if you click here we are setting a
debugging point
then if you run iis express here your
application will hit the debugging point
when we load that page
so if we click on category it will hit a
debugging point
you can see that is yellow now and if
you hover on the category list you can
see there is one count
if you expand it more you can see it is
the same record that we created inside
the database
so it goes to the database it fetches
the categories and it does that
automatically
we have a list that is already populated
here we just need to pass this list to
our view and we can run for each loop on
that list and we can display all the
categories
let's do that in the next video
let me remove the breakpoint and let's
do that in the next video
now that we have all the categories
inside this particular object we can
copy that and we will pass that to our
view
and i do not like using variables here i
am a fan of using the strongly type so
this will be i innumerable of category
we will have to press ctrl dot to add
the using statement
now since we have an i enumerable here
and not a list if you want you can also
remove the dot to list
that is not a required thing but if this
was a list then you would have used the
dot to list
so we are passing that to our view
now that we are passing an i innumerable
of category to our view we need to
capture that inside our view as well
so let me open up that view i have right
here
but if you do not have that open you can
go to category and index view
so right here we first need to capture
the model that we are passing from the
controller
for that you will be using accurate sign
and you will write model in all lower
case
if you make this a capital model that
won't work
in order to fetch what is being passed
from the view you have to use a lower
case at the rate model sign
so what exactly is being passed from the
controller action method it is an i
enumerable of category
we can copy this and we can paste that
right here
that way our view knows that whatever we
receive here will be an innumerable of
category
since it is i enumerable we can iterate
through that
now if you have never worked with razer
pages
you can use both html as well as some c
sharp code directly inside the view
so first let's use the table attribute
gives that some classes of table
table bordered to give it a border
and we'll say table striped
we can also give it a style of width 100
percent
inside the table we have t head and t
body
let me add both of them
so t head will be for headers
so we will have a tr tag in there and a
t h tag what will be all the columns
that we have to display
the first one will be category name
and the next one will be display order
you can also display the date time and
id if you want but we just want to
display two columns
that is the header
now inside the body
we will need a for each loop to iterate
through the i enumerable and display the
actual values
as i said before we can use the sharp
code directly inside the views using the
add the rate directive
so if you press at the rate you will see
we have a for each right here
syntax is pretty simple we will create a
wire here we can call that obj
and that is inside our model of the page
so on top we use the lower case model
but here model will have the first
letter as capital
so you can see how it is different
that way it will iterate through all of
the properties inside this model in for
each loop now for each of the property
we want to display a table row so we
will add dr here in that we want the td
tag first we want to display the name
so again that name is inside the c sharp
variable object so we will use the at
the right sign and we will say obj dot
name
i can give it a width of 50 percent here
and we can copy this and paste it one
more time
then we have display order so we will
say obj dot display order
let's give it a width of 30 percent
this looks great let me save this and
run the application
if we go on category now you will see
our one category that we have inside the
database
this is looking perfect to display all
of the categories
next what i want is edit and delete
buttons here and i want to make this a
little bit more pretty
for that i will be using boots watch
themes and let me show you that in the
next video
loves a pretty application
because of that i want to use
bootswatch.com which has three themes
for bootstrap
if we scroll down i want to use this
solar theme for our project
we can hit the download button and let's
download the bootstrap.css
let's open that file and it is using
bootstrap 5. that's perfect
let's copy this complete bootstrap
and let me stop the application
like ww root where we have css our
bootstrap is inside the lib folder but
here let me just create a new item
style sheet
we'll call that boots watch theme and
let me add that
i will paste the theme that we copied
and we will be using this in our project
looks good let me save this
another change i would do is inside
site.css
they have added a btn primary so let me
remove that and the anchor tag
we will be using what is there inside
our boots watch theme
in order to add this to our project we
will have to go to underscore layout and
we should have our css at the very top
this time we do not want the default
bootstrap theme
we want to use our bootswatchtheme.css
now since we are using bootstrap 5 with
bootspot if we go to bootstrap.com
let's click on getting started in
production we are in bootstrap 5.
let me copy the js bundle that we have
here
we will copy that
and we will go back to our project
inside the underscored layout
let me replace the js bundle that we
have
with the one that we copied
as of this recording the default version
of bootstrap is not five in dot net six
this might change in future but that is
the reason i'm switching to the latest
version of bootstrap
with that change let's run the
application and see if something is
different
great you can see a dark theme has been
applied so things are getting different
let me switch back to the boots watch
and let me go back to the theme that we
have
let's click on preview
here we have a navbar let's use that
i will copy everything that we have here
let's go back to our application and i
will paste that right here before the
navbar that we have
now since we are making changes inside
the view if you remember when we created
the project i enabled the razer runtime
compilation
so what that should do is when we save
here and if we go back to our
application and refresh it should load
the changes because we are making
changes directly inside the view
but that does not seem to work as you
can see
the reason behind that is we added the
package of razer runtime compilation
even though these are razer pages if you
examine the program class file we are
only adding controllers with views
we will have to make one small change
here on builder.services
we will have to add razer pages
and on that we have add razor runtime
compilation
i don't know why it is like that i
believe in future they will also add
this with the views but right now this
is only available with razer pages
so this is one extra line that we have
to add in an mvc project to get that
runtime compilation
with that change let's run the project
one more time
and great we see the new navigation menu
right here
we don't want everything else here let
me comment that we will just add the
home and category
let me go back here to underscore layout
and i can just copy the home
let me cut this
i can paste that right here
let me scroll down but we have the other
category controller
cut that
and we will paste that
instead of features
perfect i will remove these two the one
in drop down i can just leave that in
comments so that in future if we want to
drop down we can use that
and i can remove the nav bar all
together
let's go back and refresh and great this
time we did not have to rebuild the
application
the text here is not visible
so let me go back
and we don't want the text dark anymore
we can remove that
and perfect looks much better
if you click on home page it loads the
home page and category should display
all the categories
great i also want to hide this border so
that should be inside footer
we have border top we can remove that
and we can give it a background of bg
dark
let's go back and refresh
and this looks much better
so with this now we are using bootstrap
5 in our project and we are using the
bootswatch theme
let's continue in the next video
inside our index view what we can do is
we can add a button here to create a
category
so if we go back to our index let me add
a little bit of more designing with
bootstrap we will add a div give it a
class of container and padding of three
these are just the bootstrap classes
in that we will add a div give it a
class of row and padding top of four
let me add text here
save that and go back
that will create a new row right here
i want to divide this row into two parts
by default bootstrap divides each row
into 12 parts if we want but if we just
want to divide it in two parts then we
will have six in one and six in the
other
so here we will add a div give it a
class of column six
that will combine the first six in one
div and we will add another div
give it a class of column six
so that will divide the screen in two
parts
the first one we want to display and
heading so h2 give it a class of text
primary
and we want to display category list
here
let me save this go back and refresh
and looks good
let me close this container at the very
end
so we'll close that div at the end
and right here we want to add a button
right here we want to add a link
inside there we want to go to a new
action method that we will create inside
the category controller
that will be for creating a new category
so right here we will say that should go
to the same controller
which is the category controller and it
should go to an action method which will
be create
we do not have that yet but we will
create that in the next video
we can also add couple of bootstrap
classes btn btn primary and here we can
say create new
category
let me save this go back and refresh and
we have our button
let's align this button on the right
hand side in bootstrap 5 we have text
end
we will save that and that will bring it
to the right side
then let me just leave couple of lines
here i can just add few br tags
and this looks much better
now i also want to use some icons here
like font awesome
but with bootstrap 5 they have given
their own sets of icons
so why don't we use that
if you go to getbootstrap.com
we have the icons tab
getting started with all of these icons
is super simple
i used to like font awesome but you had
to register and do lots of thing this is
available quickly you just click the
install button
and you have the cdn you copy that
go to the underscore layout
styles we will paste the cdn
the icons are readily available to use
let's go back to the bootstrap
and right here let me search for plus if
you scroll down we have this plus circle
if you click there we have the link here
we will copy
and we just paste it before create
category
let me add a space
let's save that
and you will see the icons are working
perfectly
super easy to get started
with that we have added icons
but if you click the create new category
you will see page not found
that is because it is going inside
category controller create action method
but inside category there is no action
method with the name of create
so let's add that in the next video
let me copy the index action method and
we can paste that one more time we will
have to change the name here to create
and this will be a get action
method now when someone hits the create
button we will give them the option to
enter their name and display order and
create a category
so when the view is being loaded you do
not have to pass any model
you can keep that blank and then you can
create a model directly inside the view
what do i mean by that
let me create a view here we will right
click add view
razer view
we will keep that empty and looks good
let me add that
now previously when we were working with
index i said that this is the model that
will be passed from the controller
that is true but it is not always the
case
like in our create we are not passing
anything from our controller
but we still want to work on the
category model and we want to fetch its
properties when we submit the form so
for that also you will have a model for
this view
that model will be the category model
so the model that you write inside view
is not always the model that is passed
from the controller but if you are
passing a model from the controller it
must match what you have inside the
model in the view
but if you are not passing anything
inside the controller like in create
then you can find your view with a model
based on the data that you're collecting
on the page
here we are collecting the name and
display order we will use category so
that we can use tag helpers to find
everything for us
now you might be thinking what is this
new term tag helpers
i will walk you through that but before
that let me create a form here give it a
method of post because we will be
posting our data
because we want to create our category
in that i will create a div give it a
class of order padding of 3 and margin
top of 4.
in there i will add a div give it a
class of row
and padding bottom of two
and we will add a heading here which
will have a class of text primary
for the yellow color
and we will display the heading which is
create category
let me add a hr here save this and run
the project
i want to see the view while we are
building that
so if we go to our category now
and if we hit the create category button
it will take us to the create category
view that we created
here i want to display a label and a
text box
so outside of this div i will add
another div give it a class of margin
bottom three
in there we want to display a label
you can just do label and give it a name
like this that will work
but what we want to do is we want to
bind everything on this page with our
category model
because of that the dotnet core team has
provided tag helpers which starts with
asp so here we have asp hyphen 4
when we add that in a label we can use
any of the properties from our model so
you can see it is already displaying
created date time display order name and
id
we will select name here and we do not
have to populate anything else
if we go back and if we refresh the
output will be same
because what it does here
is it displays the name of the property
inside our category model
so we have it as name so that is what it
will display in the ui as well
let's go back to the create view
and now we want an input field
so we will say input and we will just
say asp4 tag helper this input is for
name
that way it will do all the binding and
when this form is posted it will post an
object of this category class with the
name populated
we can give it a bootstrap class of form
control
let me save that and refresh oops i
close that let me run it again
and create you can see a text box right
here
this looks good let me also add a text
box for the other field which is display
order so i will just copy this paste it
here the asp4 will be display order this
time
let me save that go back and refresh
and great this looks good
you can notice the name of the label is
display order without a space and that
is because inside category that is the
property name itself
we will fix that in just a second but i
wanted to show that
now let me add a button here to actually
submit the form and i will add a link to
go back to the index page of the
category controller
so we'll go to create here
and we will add a button give it a type
of submit
we will also give it some bootstrap
classes of btn btn primary
and i will give it a width of 150 pixels
i will call this button as create
next i want to add a link here this link
i want to go back to the index action
method inside the category controller to
load all of the categories
so it is more like a back button link
so first what is the controller name
that is the category controller and what
is the action in there that is the index
action
we will give it some bootstrap classes
ptn ptn secondary
and i will also give it a style with the
width of 150 pixels
within here we will display back to list
let's go back
and looks better
if we click on back to list you can see
that is functional
now in the next video we want to hit the
create button and create our category
with that let's continue from the next
video
now i want to create the category when
we populate the details and hit the
create button
so when we hit the create button we will
have to create a post action method
inside the category controller
and in that post action method we will
already be fetching the category object
that is populated because we used tag
helpers
so inside the category controller we can
copy this create and paste that one more
time let me stop the application
inside the parameters we will be
receiving a category object let me call
that obj
this will be boost action method
now if an action method is post we have
to write the attribute http post
on top of that the dotnet team has a pro
and then we also have to validate the
anti-forgery token
anti-forgery token is there to help and
prevent the cross-site request 4gb
attack
what it basically does is inside any
forms that you have inside the
application it will automatically inject
a key there
and that key will be validated at this
step
that key must be valid to prevent the
cross-site request forgery
i have explained the cross-site request
forgery and the validate anti-forgery
token in much details inside free
content on.net mastery if you search and
look for cross-site request forgery you
can find that video on youtube and watch
that
i do not want to change the focus of
this course so we will just validate
that token on all of the post request
this is not required but i will highly
recommend that to avoid the cross site
request forgery
now once we have the category object
that is populated with name and the
display order we want to create that
record inside the database
so to do that we will use our db context
and on that we have the categories
then in order to retrieve categories we
did not have to write anything else but
when we have to add something to the
table we have to add method there and
you can see it expects a category entity
we already have that inside the obj that
is what the user populated
so we will add that to our database
now once you add it to the database it
is not pushed to the database right now
it will be pushed to the database when
you run the command underscore db dot
save changes
at that point it goes to the database
and saves all the changes
once the changes are saved we have
written view here that will take us back
to the same category view
let's see when we are done let's go back
to the index so that we can see the new
category that was created
so rather than return view we want to
redirect to an action
we want to redirect to the index action
it will look for this index inside the
same controller
if you had to go to an action method in
some other controller you can define the
controller name right here
but since we are in the same controller
we can just mention index and that will
work
let's run our application and try this
out
let's go to our category
and let's create a new category
i will call this test display order 12
and great you can see it has been
created
if we go back to our sql server let me
close this
and if we do select top thousand
now we see two records
so perfect this is working as expected
and we are able to create a new category
now
but our create category is not perfect
if you hit the create button you will
run into an exception
let me switch back to the project
and you can see the exception is cannot
insert now inside the column name
we do not have any validations but
inside database we said that this was a
not nullable column
so when the entity framework code tries
to save it gives the exception pretty
smart
but we have to be much smarter to handle
the validations
let's take a look at them in the next
video
now when we try to create a category
without any fields populated right now
we see some error message because it
cannot add an object when in the
database we have validation
but that is not a good approach because
we are throwing exception in that case
what should happen is we should handle
our validations inside the server side
which is controller as well as inside
client side which is inside the create
view
so how do we handle validations
let's first do that at the server side
so when we receive a model here we can
check whether this model is valid or not
and what defines a valid model is the
validations that we have right here
name should be a required property
so let's go back and let's make sure
that our model is valid
in order to check that with net core we
have model state dot is valid
that will determine if the model is
valid or not
if that is valid we want to create and
redirect to index if that is not valid
we just return back to the view with the
object
let me run this and show you what
happens
i'll add a debugging point on if the
model state is valid
so let's run our application
let's try to create a category with no
fields populated
we hit our breakpoint and if you examine
the isvalid flag is false
so our model state is not valid
great but now which property in our
model state is not valid it is important
to know that because right now we just
have two properties it could be possible
we have over 50 properties in a model
so in that case you hover on model state
you expand that inside the error counts
you see we have two errors
if you hover on the values here
result view you will see which
properties are not valid you can see
display order is not valid as well as
name is not valid
let's continue here and this time let me
populate display order and hit the
create button one more time
model state will still be not valid but
this time if you examine the error count
is only one because we already fixed one
of the errors by providing display order
so now you can see display order is
valid but name is still invalid because
it is a required field
our server side validations are working
but with that it would be helpful if we
are displaying an error message right
here so that user can know why it is
failing
doing that is super simple
we will remove the breakpoint here and
let me go to the view
just like we have asp4 tag helper we
also have a tag helper for validation
so inside name we can add a span tag and
we have the tag helper asp validation
for
on this you have to define the model so
we want to check validations for name
here and if there are any errors we want
to display them in red color
so we can give it a bootstrap class of
text danger
we will copy this pan and we will paste
that for display order as well
with that in place make sure to save
this and we will go back and refresh the
page
let me just reload this
and this time if you try to hit the
create button you can see the default
error message is displayed
the first one that we have is name is a
required field and display order while
you know is invalid because it's an
integer
so with that we can display the default
error messages right here
so with that we have our server side
validations in which it checks at the
controller level if the model state is
valid or not
if it is not valid it populates the
model state with error message
it returns back the obj and it
automatically displays the validations
that we have added
we did not have to write javascript or
any other complex code it is doing all
of that with the help of tag helpers
let's continue in the next video
with server side validations what if you
want to display a summary at the top
with all the error message
if you want to do that dot net core has
a solution for that
you will need a div this time and not a
span that you were using with validation
for
and inside div you can see we have a tag
helper asp validation summary
this will be all
in this case it will display all the
validations at the top in a summary
format
once we make this change let's go back
and refresh here if you hit create
great now you see the error messages at
top as well
when you select all it will display
models as well as properties
if you want to limit that you can change
that to model only and none
but if you are using validation summary
i personally like all and this is great
now along with that what if we want to
add some custom validation
like let's say inside the controller
here we want to make sure that we do not
add any category which has the same name
and display order
how can we add that to the validation
so before we confirm if the model state
is valid we can check here if obj dot
name is equal equal to obj dot display
order
we will have to convert that to a string
if this is the same we want to tell our
model state that this is not valid
so for that on the model state itself we
can add custom model errors
here we have a key and value pair
you can give any key name that you want
we will call this custom error
if you want you can also use string dot
empty
but since this is a key you have to make
sure that you do not use the same key
two times
let me add a custom error that the
display order cannot exactly match the
name now since we are making a change
inside the controller we will actually
have to restart our application to see
this change
if we were working with the view we did
not have to restart
let's go to our category
and try to create a category with the
same name and display order this time
you can see we have our custom
validation that is being displayed in
the summary
now if we did not have summary then this
would not have been displayed
but what if you want to display the
error message inside name as well
it is pretty simple we will stop the
application and the key we will just
change that to name
because inside the category object if
you notice we have name so inside
controller we are adding a new error
inside the name property
let's run this and give that a try
let's go to our category
and try to create a new category
with the same name and display order
great now you see it displays in both
places
so with this we have seen how to add
custom error message
but all of the validations that we have
so far are done on the server side
every time you hit the create button you
will see the page will reload
so that means we are hitting server
every time
even if the name and display order are
empty we go back and hit the server
because the page reloads
what if we want to make all of these
validations on client-side
let's do that in the next video
now if you want to do the basic model
validations like name and value for the
display order on the client side it is
pretty simple
if you examine inside the shared folder
we have a validation scripts partial
that is using
jquery.validate
it is inside a partial view so if we
want to do client-side validations we
just have to include this partial view
in our view
so that brings the big question how do
we use a partial view we have not
created one but we are using the one
that is already available
it's not a rule but typically it's good
to name partial views with underscore
so even if in future when we create a
partial view we will follow that
convention
now in order to include a partial view
it is pretty simple you can directly say
partial
and then you have to write name of the
view
so make sure to type the exact name
if you have a spelling mistake there
then this won't be included
with that the errors go away
but inside the partial view if you open
up we have script files
so we need to add that inside a script
section of our view
so here we will have to create a section
for scripts
and in there we will have to add our
partial view and that tool inside razor
syntax
once you add this let's run the
application one more time and see the
magic
let's go to our category
and let's try to create a new category
we will hit the create button
you see we get the validations but we
are not going to server this time
all the validations are done on client
side because of the script that we
included
to double check you can just add a
debugging point here
and hit the create button it will never
reach our debugging point
it will reach our debugging point if the
name and display order are the same then
the client-side validations are valid
the validation that fails is the server
side custom validation that we added
and if you continue
perfect you can see that in action
so with this we can see how easy it was
to add client-side validation
let's continue in the next video
now that we have added the client-side
validations i want to show you one more
thing
right now we have the default message
that is being displayed
right now we have the default message
that is being displayed
on top of that you can see right now in
display order there is no space that is
available and it is the same with the
validation
the reason behind this is if we go to
our category model you can see that's
the property name and that is exactly
what is being displayed
so if we want to display something that
is not the same as property name
we have display name here which is
inside component model
and here we can just give whatever name
we want to display so let's add a space
there and it will correct that
automatically
let's run this and give that a try
let's go to our category
create category
and this time you see in errors we have
a space
labels we have a space and perfect
looks good
now if you go on the official
documentation there are quite a few data
annotations that you can use
we see the required one that we saw
we also have a range attribute i won't
go into all of them you can explore them
when you want you can see the display
attribute that we used now let's just
try one more which is the range
attribute
that specifies a range for a field so
let me just close this
and we'll stop the application
inside our display order we will add a
range attribute and here we have minimum
and maximum value
so let's say minimum is one maximum is
hundred
so now if the display order is not in
the range it will give an error message
but the error messages that we see on
the screen with validations are also
customizable
so with range if we want some other
error message we have that property
right here and we can give a custom
error message
we will have our custom error message as
display order must be between 1 and 100
only with 2 exclamation
let's run our application
and see that in action
let's hit create we have our required
one let me add something more than 100
and you can see it directly displays our
custom validation
with that you can see everything is
working as expected and we saw how to
add custom error messages arrange
validation and how to use display name
now inside our create view i will hide
or comment the validation summary
because we don't want that right now the
inline validations are sufficient
let me go back and remove the debugging
point everything looks good so far
from the next video we want to work on
editing and deleting our category
now that we have the create
functionality working as expected let's
work on the edit functionality
for edit we will go to category
controller and just like we have the
create get and create post we will copy
that and paste it one more time
this time we will call them for edit
so let me change the action method names
here one thing that will be different
for edit is when the page is loaded it
will display the existing functionality
of the category that was selected
here we will retrieve an integer which
will be id
based on that id we have to retrieve the
category details and display them
so we can check here if id is now
or if id is equal to zero
in those cases we will return back not
found because that is an invalid id
if that is not the case we will retrieve
the category from database so category
from db
and we will extract that using our
underscore db dot categories
now this will retrieve complete list of
all the tables
so on that we have few more ways of
finding one of the entity
first is single or default which returns
only one element every time
it will throw an exception if there is
more than one element
id is a primary key so there is no
chance that there will be more than one
element
similarly we have single
the difference between single and single
or default is single will throw an
exception if no elements are found for
that id
but single or default will just return
empty if there are no elements
so default will not throw exception if
the element is not found
similar to single or default we also
have first and first or default the
difference between single or default and
first or default is that single or
default will throw an exception if there
are more than one elements
first or default will not throw an
exception it will return the first
element of the list
so if more than one elements are found
first or default will return one element
singular default will throw an exception
last but not the least we have one
method which is find
find basically tries to find that based
on the primary key of the table
we know that id is the primary key so we
can use find here and pass the id
it will find the category based on that
id and assign that to our variable
let me also show you how you can use
first or default with find you just had
to pass the id
with first or default you have to pass
an expression here where we will have a
generic object let's call that u and we
will say u goes to u dot id should be
equal to the id that we have
if that matches in any of the category
row retrieve that and give me the first
one out of them let me copy this and
paste it one more time for single or
default the syntax will be same we will
just use single or default and let me
call this variable
single
so these are three ways to retrieve a
category from database based on the id
i will comment two of them out but i
wanted to show you how that could be
done using entity framework core
now once we retrieve the object we will
check here if category from db
if that is no that means again we will
return not found
if we find that category we will return
that category to the view
so next what we will do is we will
create this view which will have the
category loaded and we just need to
display that
that view will look exactly same as the
create view but the only thing different
will be that it will be for edit page
so we can copy the view that we have for
create inside category folder and paste
that one more time i can rename this to
edit to give us a head start
let's open that edit view
our model will be the category model but
rather than create category this will be
edit category
now when we edit a category we want the
validations so that will stay the same
the button text will change that from
create to update
and it is just submitting back
we do not have which action method it
should submit to if you do not provide
any name here it will by default submit
to the same action that is of the name
of the get
so since the get is from edit it will
post that to the same action method
which is edit
but if you want to be explicit about the
action you can use that with the tag
helper asp action
and you can write edit like that
so if you want you can be explicit but
that is not required
the back to list will stay the same
so with that in place if we want to see
this in action let's go to the index
view of category where we are displaying
everything i want to add a link to
navigate to the edit action method there
will be three columns here let me add
another tx tag and inside the td we will
have one with the links
so inside this td we can add a div with
a class of width 75 and btn group we can
also give that a role of group
in there let me add an anchor tag and we
will use tag helpers inside this anchor
tag this will be for edit and if we go
back and if we open up the bootstrap
icon let's try to find an icon for edit
we have this pencil square let me copy
that and paste that here
let's run the application and we will
get back to the index in just a second
while the application loads let's get
back here
so this edit should take us to category
controller and edit action method
so if we go back here we want the asb
controller it has to go to the category
controller
asp action it should go to the edit
action
that is great
but if we go take a look at our
controller action method it also expects
an id
so we have to pass that id with our link
we can pass custom variables here so we
can say asp route and then what is the
name of the variable
that is id right here
so we will just say id here this we will
have to bind with our object so we'll
say at we have obj dot id
you can see how dynamic we can get with
the razer pages
with that let's go back and refresh go
to category we should see the edit
button yep that is here
you can see if you hover on edit you can
see the url where the id is changing
if you click edit here it will take us
to edit category and it automatically
populates the name and display order
our back to list is also working as
expected
to make this button look pretty we can
just add two css classes ptn btn primary
and some margin
let's go back and refresh and this looks
much better
so our edit get action method is working
as expected
in the next video let's work on updating
our category
now we are able to load the category
that we want to edit
when the user hits the update button it
will go to category controller we have
the post action method for edit
you can have the same validation that we
had there but if all the validations are
valid we do not want to call the ad we
want to call the update method on our
categories db set
this is a built-in method with ef core
where based on the primary key it will
automatically update all of the
properties
and you do not have to do any manual
update it will take a look at the obj
right here
and it will find its primary key
retrieve that from the database it will
check all the other properties where the
values have changed and it will update
all of those
so you can see it is handling all the
complexity and we just need an update
statement to update any of the category
based on the
id after that make sure that you are
saving the changes and we are
redirecting back to the index action
if you examine here you can see all the
options that are available with our db
set we have add remove add async at
range that will add multiple objects at
the same time we have update and much
more
for this time we'll select update and we
will have to restart the application
since we made some changes to the
controller
let's go to our category and let's try
to edit any of the category
and great you can see update is working
successfully
now the last part that i want you guys
to implement yourself is to add a button
or a link here to delete any of the
category once you do that it should take
you to a details page like edit category
but this will say delete category and
the fields will be disabled
then there will be a button to delete
and when you click that on the post it
will delete the category and take you
back to the index page
it is exactly same as what we did with
edit category but rather than update you
will have to find what keyword to use to
delete the category
also i want to show you that inside edit
our validations are working
if you hit update here you can see it
does not let you update you go back the
data stays the same
so all the validations are working as
expected but in the delete category we
will not need any validations because
you have to make sure that the fields
are disabled
so good luck with the assignment and
i'll show you how to do that in the next
video
the last functionality we want to work
on is the delete functionality inside
category
so we will copy edit as is
and we will paste that one more time
both get and post
i will change this to delete
and we will use the same name right here
for the post action method
when we are deleting a category we want
to retrieve that category and we want to
display that on the view
so this functionality stays the same
with the get action method
now with the boost action method you can
either push the complete object or you
can just pass the id here so we will
have integer id and based on that id we
will first retrieve that category
now i do not need any model state
validations so i will remove them
all i have to do is based on the id i
have to retrieve the category
so i'll say variable obj is equal to
underscore db dot categories dot find
based on the id we will find that if
there is null we will return not found
else on categories we have remove and we
will remove the object save the changes
redirect back to the index page
that looks perfect
but we see an error with the name
we cannot have same signature with the
name and the parameters for two action
method
so for now let me rename this to delete
post
let's work on adding the delete view it
will be same as edit because we will be
displaying them so let me copy edit
paste it one more time
i will rename this as delete
let me close all the other views so that
we don't confuse ourselves this will be
delete category and the button let me
make it danger since we are deleting
we do not want any validations and the
fields will be disabled
so let me copy that as well
now the post action name is added but we
have renamed the post method to delete
post so we will copy that
and paste that right here
let's run our application and give this
a try
let me go back and add a debugging point
right here
let's go to our category
and we forgot to add the delete button
inside the index view
i will copy this and paste it one more
time
this will be for delete
rather than square we will have to look
for delete icon
so let me look for a trash can
the get action will be delete so we will
use that
let's go back and refresh
we have edit and delete let me give it a
different color
and perfect
now if you try to hit the delete button
it will take you to the delete category
let's see what happens when we hit
delete button
it will hit our breakpoint and you
examine the id is null
now why is this id null
it was not null when we were editing but
in delete this is null
the reason behind that is inside delete
let me hit continue here
and it will take us to not found page
that's perfect but the reason behind
that is inside delete all of the fields
for our model is disabled
if one of them was enabled id is primary
key that's why it was automatically
being set on the forum
so in this case what we will do is we
will have an input field with the tag
helper asp4 id that's the only field we
care about and we will keep it hidden
since it is inside the form when the
form is posted we will retrieve that id
right here
let's go back
and let me refresh let's hit the delete
button
this time the id is populated
so now if you hit continue now if you
are editing you make some change you get
this error message but i believe with
visual studio 2022 they are just giving
that right now and it will be fixed
later on
in that case just rerun the application
so let's go to category here
and try delete one more time
perfect that category was deleted
but that delete is working as expected
but i want to show you one last thing
right now inside delete we have the
action as delete post
what if we want it to be delete
in this case it won't work because the
controller will know that the action
method name here is delete post for post
so if you want to explicitly give that a
different name
we have action name attribute right here
and we can give it
delete
that way the controller will know that
if a request comes in for delete action
method http post inside the category
controller that is this particular
action method
so let me run that and show you that
this also works
so let's go to category
and delete one more category perfect
so with that all the functionality are
working as expected
i want to display some alerts when
someone deletes edits or create a
category on the category index view
how will we do that
for that we have something called a
stamp data in dotnet core
temp data has been provided with one
single purpose
whatever we want to store in temp data
stays there for only one request
after that if you refresh the same page
that will be gone
so that is perfect for displaying alerts
of successful or failure notification
let's take a look at how will we do that
let's say right now that when we create
or edit or delete anything we will add
something to attempt data of success
so once the create is successful here
before we redirect we want to use temp
data it is directly available as you can
see
so temp data and then you have to give
any key inside there
so let me call this temp data of success
and we will store a message there that
category created successfully
on create post
if they are editing
let me store category updated
successfully in delete i will say
category deleted successfully
so we are storing some string inside
temp data with the key of success
now where do we want to extract this
we want to extract that inside the index
view
so at the top here
we can check if temp data of success is
not null
the main important thing is the key name
must exact match if you use a different
key name this will not work
so if this does match inside an h2 tag
let me display temp data
and the value inside that
let's save this and run our application
to see what happens
with that change let me try to create a
new category
great you can see we have category
created successfully
now since this is in temp data if you
refresh this will go away
so it only stays in memory for just one
redirect
and after that it goes away if we try to
edit any of the category
we get the error of course
we see category updated successfully
when we delete we get the deleted
successfully
if you refresh that goes away
so this is great when you have to
display notifications on some of the
actions that are performed
now this time data can be used
throughout the application and not just
one page
so why not when we are checking this
temp data success and displaying that do
that at a global level so we do not have
to add this in all the pages
for that partial views will be a perfect
candidate we can have some code inside
the partial view and we can call that
partial view everywhere we want
because right now it is four lines of
code but it is possible that this code
will increase drastically when you do
something fancy for notification
so let's move this code inside a partial
view and see how we can call that
now that we have added a code to display
some of the alerts and notification we
want to make sure that this code is
applicable on almost all the pages
because if in future we add more pages
we don't want to copy and paste the same
code in all the places
so the best thing is inside the shared
folder we will create the partial views
that is the folder that i like to place
all of my partial views
we will stop the application
right click add
view
we will go with the razer view not the
mt1 and here we will select create as a
partial view
we did not do that earlier but now we
will do that
that will create an empty partial view
i forgot to give that a name so i'll
have to rename this once it is created
it's just view we will change that to
underscore
notification
what we want to do is the temp data chat
that we have here let me copy and paste
that here
and it will do its check
since we have attempt data for success
we can also implement attempt data for
error so we can display both success and
error notifications
so great now inside index we can just
say partial here
and we can say name is equal to
underscore
notification
pretty clean right
let's say in future you want to add this
to multiple pages you just have to add
this partial tag and that will be done
let's run our application and see if our
partial view is working as expected
let's try to create a new category
and grid that is working if we refresh
that goes away
so with that our partial views are
working as expected
than displaying a text as an alert why
don't we use something fancy like
toaster
so we have toaster.js
so with toaster if we go to the github
page we have a javascript notification
that we can use
if you go to demo here and hit show
toast this notifications are much
cleaner and easier to read
in order to use that we will copy the
minified js and css files
let's add that to our project in the
underscore layout
now the css file we will be adding right
here
so we'll say link rel is equal to
stylesheet
and the href let's go back and copy just
the css
so we will copy this
and paste it right here
now the gs file will be required at the
underscore notification level
so we will have to go back
copy the gs file
and we need to include that right here
so we will have to use a script here
src
let's paste that
also when we are using toaster we will
need the jquery reference that is inside
lib we have the jquery dist
jquery.min.js
so we will have to add both of them in
both the places
next we need the toaster alert so if we
go back we should have a usage right
here
we have toaster.warning
toaster.success we will use it exactly
like this
so if we go back here if we have success
that is populated we need a javascript
code so we'll add a script tag
we will say type is equal to text
forward slash javascript
and i will use toaster.success
and display everything inside temp data
of success
make sure here you are using the single
quotes and then you need the accurate
sign for accessing the c sharp variable
let's copy the script tag and paste that
for error
and this looks great
so with that we have added toaster.js in
our website
if we go back even while the application
is running
these are just the javascript changes so
you can refresh the page here
and let's try to edit something in the
category
and great we see our toaster alerts here
and everything is working as expected
now let's say this notification is
something you will have across all the
pages
in that case it does not make sense to
add this one line in all the pages
even though it's just one line it just
doesn't make sense
so rather than adding this in all the
pages you can add that in underscored
layout and that will be included in all
the pages
so just before render body where we have
all the body that we render for the page
we will paste our partial view and that
will make sure that it is included in
all the pages of your application
so make sure that you include only
things that are needed across all the
pages because this will be loaded every
time your page loads
so with that if we go back and refresh
and try to delete a category
our toaster alerts are working as
expected
now that our application is up and
running and everything looks good
i want to show you one thing with the
controller
we added the controller ourselves and we
also created all the views
but with dotnet core we have some help
if you want
so if we try to add a controller this
time we will implement the same logic
but with mvc controller with views using
entity framework
we will hit add here
and this will create an mvc controller
with views using entity framework on a
model
so we will select our model category on
that we want the crud operations
let's select a data context that will be
used to access the database
and we will give our controller a name
i will leave the default name but rather
than categories i will say categories
temp controller since i want to delete
that later on
let's add this and see what happens
this will scaffold everything for us it
will create a new category stamp
controller and it will create the views
for create edit delete details and index
you can see the new controller it has
all the action methods as well as the
post action methods
and inside the category stamp it has
added five views
let's run the application and see the
change
in order to navigate that we will have
to manually type category stem
it takes us to the view here where we
have the index view it displays our
category
we can create a new category here
with this it also asks us to input the
created time let's do that
you can see it is not as efficient
because it does not know that
createddatetime will be the default one
so it asks the user to input that but
you can create that edit that go back
view the details and you can also delete
any of the requests
so all the crud functionalities with the
views are ready for you and generated in
just a minute
but you'll have to spend time on
customizing this based on your
requirement
the reason i did not want to go into
this directly is i wanted you to spend
some time and learn how to do everything
from scratch
but once you know this you can take a
look at the controller action method
most of the code will be the same
but that is also an option that is
available
with that
let me remove the temp controller that
we added as well as the views
with that our application is complete
let's see how we can deploy this to
azure and see everything live on the
internet
now the final task is to deploy our
application to azure
so for that you will have to create an
account on portal.azure.com
i already have an account
if you are signing up for the first time
you will get 200 dollars of free credit
that you can use
the first thing that we have to do in
here is we need to create a sql server
and a database inside that
so we can create or search for sql
databases
and let's hit the add button
usually i like creating everything from
visual studio but sql server i like to
create here that way i can easily see
all the configuration
you will select the subscription that
you have and in there we can create a
resource group
i will call this resource group as
dotnet mastery underscore course
and then let's enter a database name we
will call that dotnet mastery underscore
db
we do not have a server so let's create
a server
the server name will be unique so i will
use dotnet mastery server
and then we need an admin login
we cannot use admin here that won't work
so i will just use admin sql
for password you can use something
secure select your location
and hit ok
now next option is to we want to use
elastic pool
we will say no there and in the server
location that's not available
so let me select some other location
each os 2
and let's hit ok
then you need to select the compute plus
storage we will select configure
database there and i will use the lowest
option which is basic here and that is 5
usd per month let's apply
i do not want to pay more for the
subscription so i'm going with the
lowest option the redundancy backup that
is perfectly fine with me let me hit
review plus create
we will hit create here and it will take
a while to configure our database and
set everything up
and perfect our database has been
created if we click go to resource it
will take us to sql database
now one thing that you will have to do
is if you want to access this database
from your local sql server you will have
to select the set firewall settings
and add your client ip
that will enable your client ip and you
can access the database from sql server
let's hit the save button to add your
client ip there
once that is done let's go back to sql
server and we need to connect to that
server so we will hit ok here go back to
the resource and we have connection
string
let me copy the server name here
go back and paste it and we will use sql
server authentication
we have admin sql
and the password
let's press connect
great we are able to connect to our sql
server
so with that in place let's continue
from the next video let me close the
other tabs here
now we are able to connect to our
database from sql server
let's go back to our project and we want
to deploy our website to azure
for that we will right click on the
project and hit publish
we will do all the setup directly from
visual studio to create an app service
and we will use the database that we
created here we will select azure hit
the next button we will be using azure
app service for windows
if you are not signed in make sure to
sign in with the same account that you
have used to create the database on
azure portal
you will select the subscription name
here and we don't have any app servers
that are running
so we will create a new app service here
and we need to give a meaningful name
i will call this bulkybookweb and
because of that the final site name will
be bulkybookweb.azurewebsites.net
we will have our subscription resource
group if you do not have one you can
just create one it is just any name that
you want that is more like a folder
structure in which you can organize
everything together
next is the hosting plan
by default there is s1 hosting plan
i want to use the free hosting plan so
we will select new here and we will
select the free plan that is available
with azure
let me hit ok here and hit the create
button
this will take a few minutes but it will
create and configure your app service
once the app service is created we will
have to configure the connection string
and then in the new database that is
created we need to make sure that
migrations are executed
perfect this is done let's hit finish
here
then inside dependencies you see we have
sql server database
you can either configure this here or if
you just click the edit button here it
will display the database which has a
connection string
if you go back to your portal
and we will have to go to our sql
database we have the connection string
right here
we will copy this and we will paste that
here
we just need to make sure a few things
we just need to make sure that password
is populated
let me do that here
user id looks good we will say that we
want to use this connection string at
runtime
let me copy this and inside the entity
framework migrations
we want to apply migrations on publish
we will paste the connection string here
as well
let me go here to make sure password and
user id looks good
and the last option is since we are
using dot net 6 it is not available
inside the api service
so for that we will have to change the
mode to self-contained
that will have a self-contained
environment with netsex
with that let me save this and let's
publish
when it will try to run the migration in
the logs we will see one error with the
ip address
let's wait for that
and you can see it is failing here so it
should give us the error message pretty
soon
and perfect we see that here it should
be with the ip address
and there you go you can see it cannot
access this ip address that is the
server ip so let me copy that
and i will paste that in a notepad let
me copy this ip address
we will go back
and inside our database
we will set the server firewall
add that ip address
and we will save that
perfect now that should not be an issue
let's hit publish one more time
this time it should be able to push all
the migrations and deploy our code to
azure
once everything is done it will load the
website which is
bulkybook.azurewebsites.com
great it automatically opened up and
perfect this looks great
if we go to category there won't be any
category but we can create a new
category here
and our alerts are also working
so perfect with this we have seen how we
can deploy our website to azure
that being said this is only for testing
but the sql database that we have we are
getting charged for that
so let me remove all the resources and
we will also delete this profile
the reason i want to delete is i only
wanted to show you how easy it is to
deploy your code to azure
so with that let's go to all resources
select all of them and let's delete them
so with that we have seen the cred
operations that we can do with category
using mvc in dot net six
so first of all congratulations on
completing the grunt operations using
darknet 6 mvc
we have seen quite a few things in this
small course
but right now we are just getting
started with dotnet core and there is a
lot more to explore and learn when it
comes to dotnet core
even though this course has come to an
end i have advanced courses that will
take you from the basics that you have
learned here all the way to exploring
new concept
let me walk you through some of those
concepts
in the full courseof.net core mvc we
will take what we have built so far and
convert that to an anterior architecture
because that is a real world scenario
because that is a scenario that is
adopted with most complex project
then we do not interact directly with
the data context in our main project we
will be using a repository pattern and
unit of work to interact with our
database
so we will see dependency injection and
how to inject that using a repository
pattern
then we will further split our project
inside areas in.net core which is a
folder like structure but everything
gets much more organized
we have seen temp data but we will see
view back and view data with dotnet core
and see how all of them are different
next we will use suite alerts which text
editor data tables with dot net core and
api calls
with any application authentication and
authorization plays very important role
and dotnet team has given us the razer
class library which is identity in the
dotnet world
that makes all of the authentication
super simple because the basic
functionality and table structure is
already implemented for us
so we will see how to scaffold that
identity in mvc application
next with authorization we will see how
roles play an important role and how can
we modify our application based on the
role of the user that is logged in
in a real-world scenario we also accept
payments
so i will show you how to accept
payments using stripe and also give
refunds when the order is cancelled
session is one of the key feature that
was very helpful with traditional mvc
application
with net core also session is not gone
we just need to do a little
configuration and add session to our
project and we will see that in action
most of the applications will send
emails in some way
i will show you two approaches one using
the smtp server and second using
applications and grid
then with the modern applications we
have social logins like facebook twitter
and so on so i will show you how the
dotnet team has made it easy to
integrate social logins with the help of
facebook
lastly there are some advanced concepts
like view component how to see database
with tv initializer and once the data is
seated in the database our final goal is
deploying the application to azure
so you can see there are quite a few
topics that we will cover in the
advanced course but with that you will
get a solid foundation to build your
real world project
and if you like this free course please
subscribe and like this video and i will
have more free content uploaded every
month
so good luck with your journey of dot
net core and happy coding